I don't think there exists a category of
cards as underappreciated in commander
as protection spells. People just don't
play them and when they do they gloss
over some of the best ones. Yes, aside
from Tefar's protection and heroic
intervention, there's an entire trove of
treasures waiting to be unlocked. And
today we are doing just that. Hello,
this is Jyn with Next Level Commander.
And to demonstrate my authority on this
topic, I did a quick audit of my top 10
favorite decks at the moment and it had
a whopping total of 82 protection
spells. Now, I may or may not have gone
a little bit overboard here, but at
least you can trust I know my
preventative measures. In real life, we
might use our magic cards as a shield
from wanted and unwanted social
interactions. But in the game, somehow
our sense of safety goes out the window.
Yeah, just run your big expensive value
engine commander out there raw and
surprise Pikachu when it gives birth to
some monkey. Many people throw
protection spells into the same category
as combat tricks for being narrow and
low impact. Not worth a card, aside from
the aforementioned staples, of course.
But like Manarox, Wizards has been
pushing and pushing protection spells
with almost every new set. And we are
truly in the golden age of protection.
No exaggeration here. So today, we're
going to break down some of the cases
where you should absolutely be playing a
suite of protection spells and go over
some really underrated ones that can
convincingly outperform the stables in
the right scenarios. Ah, let's go. So,
what kind of decks would want protection
spells? We'll open with the most obvious
ones and go deeper from there. First up,
the keystone commanders. These are decks
that lean entirely on their commander to
function. I love building decks like
this actually because they feel unique,
breaking us out of generic archetypes,
but that strategy only works if you can
keep your lynch pin on the board. Nah,
the Eternal is an example. Your deck is
probably filled with big spells and mana
sings, and you won't find many
alternatives to NEP for doing what he
does. Rat's Lord of Riots, too. If your
deck is filled with early pingers and
giant greedy fatties, and it will fall
apart if Ratoss gets taken out. Now, I
know black and red are the worst colors
for doing this, but actually it's got
some surprisingly decent options besides
the obvious, and we'll cover them later
in the video. Next, value commanders.
The ones that generate advantage by
simply sticking around, and they more
than make up for the cards you spent to
ensure that they do. The likes of Cyus
and Tatova probably can net you two
cards a turn minimum. And Itali, for
instance, is arguably worth dumping your
entire hand to protect. And it's not
just about direct card advantage.
Something like Elishnorn, mother of
machines, for instance, doesn't draw you
cards, but getting two or three
additional ETBs a turn is more than
worth a card. Same with Feldon of the
Third Path, an extra activation can net
you so much value. And also in a similar
vein, legends that are overly expensive,
but can take over the game
single-handedly. The Aison, Jacelas, and
Omnoffs, these can easily go into
double-digit cost with commander
attacks. And as a trade-off though, them
sticking around for two to three turns
probably means game over for your
opponents. Next up are decks that tend
to commit creatures to the board early
and fast. You know, the aggro decks,
beatown decks, and a lot of Kindred
builds. You come out the gate fast,
applying pressure, but usually it's not
enough to win the game. And at the same
time, you're open to getting blown out
four for one, five for one by a single
board wipe. And this is where we go,
whoops, we got carried away, and now we
need some emergency protection. Once we
have a decent board rather than
overcommitting, hold a protection spell.
This will catch a lot of your opponents
offguard like them simic players
expecting to be able to play greedy and
clean everything up with single board
wipe. This little surprise can be one of
the best ways for aggro decks to steal
games. Our final category is commanders
that actively reward you for playing
protection spells on them. Feather goes
without saying and I have a gargos deck
with around 20 protection spells. Brigen
soldier of mitus is another example. But
aside from this, if your commander has a
solid enter the battlefield ability, the
flicker and blink type protection spells
can be excellent value and almost never
a dead card. If your deck falls into any
of these categories, playing some
synergistic protection spells will make
your deck better and more consistent.
Now, we go over some of the best choices
for different scenarios. First, the
all-rounded ones. Free is always the
number one upside for cards as
situational as protection spells, and
we've gotten some pretty sweet options.
For most decks, we want our protection
spells to be as cheap as possible
because holding up one mana is just so
much easier than holding up two in
anything that isn't a draw go deck. So,
we'll prioritize lowc cost first step.
One mana, we have access to hexroof,
indestructible, or protection from a
chosen color. They all have their pros
and cons. Indestructible is butter
against board wipes. Hex proof blanks
all spot removals, while protection from
a color is a situationally better
hexroof with the added perks of forcing
through your voltron commanders and once
in a while satisfyingly disassembling
aura decks. Another solid subset is the
flicker effects like ephemerate and
cloud shift. They're excellent for
reusing enter the battlefield commanders
and creatures, but they also don't
protect us from boardw. Oh, and I almost
forgot about them, but the mothers, they
absolutely deserve to be in this
conversation, even though I never like
them much. and because they're slow and
I have to drop them early, which makes
you even more vulnerable to getting X
for one by a board wipe. However, in
practice, I've seen them do excellent
work. And one of the best arguments for
them is the ability to deter removals
rather than trying to counter them after
cast because a removal spell safe
against Doom now might get spent on
another opponent later on. So yeah,
everything has their limitations and
this is partly why Tomio's safekeeping
is relatively popular for giving close
to complete protection from spot
removals and board wipes. Lawrence
escape is the white counterpart. Both
are solid choices, but like manow rocks,
they're continuing to push protection
spells with seemingly every set. Tyor
stand is so so versatile being a solid
protection spell in a space form, but
late game can serve as a massive mana
sync, allowing you to kill with
commander damage out of seemingly
nowhere. Another favorite of mine is
defend the rider. The one- one option is
a decent surprise chump blocker, but
more importantly, it covers a glaring
weakness of the aforementioned choices.
And we're still getting better from
here. Restoration magic bonkers. The
base tier is already excellent being
able to protect any permanent, but the
option of curaga when you have the mana
is brilliant, keeping all your
permanence alive and that six life. I
know this may seem expensive compared to
heroic intervention, but the versatility
is massive here. When it comes to the
most complete protection though, nothing
beats phasing. I'm sure users and
victims of deferious protection can
attest to that. Galadriel's Dismissal is
like a less complete but more versatile
tof protection being one of the best
singlet target protection spells for
just one mana and the kicker option is
also really reasonably costed. While
clearing out your board for a turn may
be a slightly risky play without being
protected yourself, you're probably
kicking this in response to a board wipe
anyways, so you're most likely safe.
Gladriel can also do a crappy tofarious
impression by facing out one opponent's
stuff, which is close enough in a lot of
scenarios. Yeah, card is nuts. If you
have one, play it. By now, I'm sure you
see the abundance of powerful options in
green and especially white. But what
about the other colors? Well, blue is a
bit awkward because I mean, you can just
play the low mana counter spells.
However, there are some decent one mana
options and the best one of them all
slip out the back. If the free counter
spells are outside our budget, playing
these lowc cost, low impact ones can be
justified if your deck really leans
heavily on the commander. For instance,
I have an Arami deck that is a bit all
or nothing. If I lose Arammy, I'm
playing a bunch of random Kindred cards.
With Arammy, though, I go off fast. In
this case, cards like slip out the back
and Magic Temper are justifiable. And as
always, red gets the short end of the
stick. The redirect spells can sometimes
lead to the biggest blowouts, but our
options really are limited. Aside from
these though, we'll have to rely on some
of the colorless options we'll go over
later. Black at a glance may also seem
limited, but cards like Undying Malice
and Maliker Rebirth will prevent any
destruction with the unique perk of
triggering any dying and ATB effects.
Coupled with sad cutless like high
market or fireex tower, we can also
dodge exhaust spot removals. Kaya's
ghost form is another unique one is
preemptive, so no surprise factor, but
with this attached is near impossible
for your opponents to deal with your
commander with any one removal spell.
And finally, if you squint hard enough,
Reanimate is close enough to a
Galadrio's dismissal, right? Especially
if you have sack outlets. Okay. Now, if
we try opening up the mana cost
limitation, you will discover a ton of
really interesting options. Two mana,
for instance, opens up delayed blink in
white. This is similar to phasing in
that it is a catch-all protection while
triggering the ETBs. Long roll home and
other worldly journey are excellent, but
one of my favorites in this category is
parting gust with slightly more
restrictive mana cost. This serves as a
blink spell or a removal whichever you
need more at the moment or just get both
with getaway glamour. The base is a long
rolled home but if you happen to have
extra mana or the need it also kills the
thing. These three cards are actually so
pushed I swear every single one of them
feels playable. Now this next one for
example smuggler surprise. I think
people are sleeping on this by not
evaluating it actual base mode which is
hidden at the bottom. This for two mana
does a solid heroic intervention
impression if your deck is creature
based. I mean you're in green. What else
is there to do? And the other abilities
here being mix and matchable is just so
versatile. Honestly, I think this is one
of the best green cards from recent
sets. Now, this next one is even better,
but sees even less play. Final showdown.
Unlike Smuggler Surprise, this is not a
base protection spell. It is one of the
best board wipes in the game, but being
able to give a creature indestructible
for just two mana allows this to replace
any protection spell and perform double
duty. Now, for more specific scenarios,
an aggro deck, for instance, would have
to make a choice between leaving a
protection mana or continuing to build
the board. While some cards allow you to
do both, Grand Crescendo is the top pick
in my book. Two mana to give
indestructible to everything is already
very playable. Mughal's Veiler is a less
flexible version of that, but can be
just as powerful. These cards I often
just chuck out there, make a bunch of
tokens, and apply more pressure, even if
the protection part is wasted.
Similarly, the flip aison is a solid
flying threat that is totally fine to
just play. Be careful though with the
flip ability. You don't want to wipe
your own board. Another solution to this
problem is the set and forget ones like
Selfless Spirit, Boromir, Dauntless
Escort, and Selfless Glyph Weaver. These
are all excellent, especially when
combined with creature recursion
effects. Although for any creature deck,
the best protection spell is always a
Chroma's Will. Not close. And this card
does everything. Casting it on a full
board usually means game over. Even if
they're still alive, your opponents are
never racing you after this. and using
this as a protection spell may feel bad,
but it's nice to have the option in a
pinch. Now, in decks with more ETB
effects, higher mana cost opens the door
to mass blinking. I mean, these are also
protection spells, all right, but
sometimes they can straight up win you
the game if you get enough triggers.
Now, we're getting more and more narrow
if your commander is seven power or
greater or can easily get to that point.
Not of this world is a treat from the
olden days. And besides spells, they've
also printed a bunch of equipments that
can function similarly with myithal coat
from Lord of the Rings and Celestial
Armor in Foundations. And also there's
silver shell costume. Excellent card. If
your deck has a decent amount of
instance, Veilstone Amulet is a really
interesting pick turning every instant
into protection. And at this point, if
you're still not convinced about
protection spells, somehow at least
start with the lance. Malacher Rebirth
is one. Revitalizing Repast and Sajuri
Shelter are also options with low
opportunity cost. Plaza of Heroes is
expensive, but it's a solid land even if
you never use the protection ability.
And Talon Case of Madara is one of those
freakishly pushed cards being ramp
protection and pseudo removal allin one.
So that's a decent roundup of protection
spells. I'd say please give them a try.
You will find that protecting what you
have is sometimes so much more efficient
than finding another one or recasting it
again from the command zone. Practice
safe magic. Which ones are you adding to
your decks? Do you have a commander that
synergizes unfairly well with protection
spells? Let me know in the comments. At
this point, I'm still able to read and
reply to all of them, but it's starting
to get a bit overwhelming, which is a
good problem to have. Thank you all.
This is Jyn with Next Level Commander.
Please subscribe if you enjoy this
content, and stay tuned for more. See
you.